In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion for June 9th, on which we commemorate our venerable and
God-bearing Father Columbus of Ireland, founder of the monastery of Iona.
Of royal blood, St. Columbus was born in 521 in the county of Donegal in Ireland.
His education was at first confided to St. Phineon of Moldville, who had him ordained Deacon.
Then having lived some time with a converted bard called Gemma, he entered St. Phineon
of Clonards, monastery.
There he completed his formation, particularly in the study of the Holy Scriptures, without
however, disdaining the art of poetry in which he excelled.
It was there that he joined with other saints of the time, St. Congol and St. Kenneth,
and apparently went to live near Dublin with them in a community of hermits.
As soon as he was ordained priest, he began his ministry of preaching, but he pursued
for fifteen years all over Ireland, founding many monasteries that later became famed.
In particular, those of Derry, Duro, and Kels, but of these holy places it was Derry that
he preferred, where he sang, on every oak leaf I see a heavenly angel poised.
All things breathed peace.
All is sheer delight.
At the Synod of Telto and 563 he was due to be excommunicated because it seems of a
dissension with King Diermit, but he was cleared through the intervention of St. Brendan
of Burr, who testified that the grace of God was upon him.
On the prophetic advice of St. Brendan, Columbus decided, however, to leave his fatherland
and go into exile in order to preach Christ, as so many other Irish saints of that time
had done.
On the night of Pentecost, he landed together with ten monks who were kin to him, on the
island of Iona, to the west of Scotland.
This flat and uncultivated little island, made up of sand and rock, battered by the wind
and the unleashed waves, and situated between the lands of the Picts and the Scots, was to
become, through the Saints' presence, one of the most illustrious centres of Celtic Christianity.
After having organised the monastic life there, St. Columba undertook the evangelization
of the Northern Picts, who were still savage pagans.
Preaching through an interpreter and more especially through the power of miracles, he poured scorn
on their druids.
When he arrived at King Brood's fortress, he opened its gates with the sign of the cross.
The sovereign received him with respect and confirming his right to Iona, had from then
on a great admiration for him.
Indefatigable, both in his ascetic labour and his missionary journeys, the saint founded
many daughter houses of the monastery, both in Scotland and Ireland, putting his disciples
in charge of them, but he himself kept the supervision of this monastic federation through
his gifts of insight and prophecy.
When he was not travelling, he stayed in the monastery where a great many visitors of
every rank came to admire his virtues and receive his advice.
He knelt before them, and after having washed their feet, gave them a loving embrace.
Like a father to all, he had compassion for the sufferings of each.
Healing the sick, repelling epidemics by having bred that he had blessed distributed, driving
out demons, producing favourable winds for sailors, helping farmers, reconciling separated
couples, exhorting sinners to repentance and weeping over those who did not weep enough
for themselves.
For of all his virtues, his tears were his most eloquent sermons.
His biographer, Adamin, described him in these terms.
His face was that of an angel.
His nature was that of the chosen.
He was brilliant in speech, holy in action, great in counsel.
He never wasted a moment, always praying, reading or writing, always busy.
He bore the weight of unremitting fasting and vigils.
Even one of his labors would be too much for one man's strength.
And in these labors, he seemed full of love for all, full of serenity and holiness, light-hearted
from the joy of the Holy Spirit in the depths of his heart.
Having acquired great skill in the art of spiritual discernment, he knew how to be intransigent
towards unrepentant sinners, but gentle with others.
Thus, when a thief came to steal the community's seals, he told his disciples to give him some
of the sheep as the price of his exertions and let him go.
Apart from his missions to the Picts, St. Columba did not forget his compatriots, the Scots,
who had settled in the west of Scotland.
He consecrated their king, Aiden, on Iona in 574, thus founding the Scottish Royal Line,
and intervened with the high king of Ireland to secure their independence.
From the depths of his cell, he helped them in their battles, which he described in detail
to his monks.
It is said that the Princess of the time did nothing without consulting the man of God.
After 34 years of apostolic labor in Scotland in 597, St. Columba was at the age of 70, warned
by an angel of his coming death.
He went to bless the monastery's barn, and on the way back the monks' old grey horse
cantered towards him, and put its head on his chest in tears.
The saint urged his disciples to keep a mutual and unsimulated charity in peace.
Then he resumed his interrupted copying of the salter.
When he reached the verse, they who seek the Lord shall want no manner of thing that
is good.
He stopped and designated his successor to continue his work.
Around midnight he went hastily to the church, where he collapsed before the altar.
When his disciples went to help him, he sketched a gesture of blessing and expired.
The veneration of St. Columba spread greatly, especially as the protector of Ireland, along
with St. Patrick and St. Bridget.
Later St. Aiden went from Iona to found the monastery of Lindisfarne.
Once he undertook the evangelization of Northumbria under the protection of the Holy King Oswald,
who had spent part of his exile in Iona.
After the Synod of Whitby in 664, that saw the triumph of Roman usage in the Anglo-Saxon
Federation, Iona remained until 716, the center of resistance by the Celtic tradition.
The monastery was sacked by the Normans in 802, but nevertheless remained the burial place
of the kings of Scotland until the 11th century.
After the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.